Is it possible for me to start one goddamn video
without yelling ?
Welcome everybody to LWIAY
Let's just jump into it, guys!
On 3, 2, 1
You didn't jump!
What the hell man!
I thought we were cool
Oh, well
LWIAY, for those who don't know, is the show where we review the top 10 culinary...
experiences on the internet
Number One: BuRgEr King foOt
Sorry
For anyone who asked how broken YouTube's system is
Here's that!
This is now the top voted meme everybody.
It's not even a meme it's just sad.
The three top voted memes of all time it's just shit on YouTube *laughs*
"So, I made this for Pewds and Marzia's wedding. Please let him see it, thank you"
I've seen it; Marzia showed it to me already.
It's so amazing
I love that suit, that's so cool.
Thank you @sketchylinez That's amazing, so cute!
Oh! it didn't even hit me that I was in the cart
Such a dumbass
"The first image that pops up when you search Pewdiepie on Google
it's the one that in the media keeps using.
Let's change that, 9-yr-old army,
Finally ! Now media record can represent me in an accurate way.
Thank you so much
77 Million FOURTEEN yrs old, everybody
This is E P I C
I'm so proud of this community
Can we give a shout-out to all wahmen
"Suicide rate drops to 0%"
OMG, is it gonna do it every single time?
It needs to change color, though.
I t's not the same satisfaction if it doesn't change color
PewDiePie shakes hands with fan whose cousin's  neighbor's stepsister's mailman is a Nazi
Alright, guys. It's over...
This time, I'm 100% guilty. I'm sorry.
I'm going through
I can't even bother to do the joke
It's not even funny, allright moving
THE NEXT TARGET
YouTube gaming
Youtube gaming
HO HO HO
"In Romania we had news about your battle versus T-series"
Thank You Romania, very cool
That's very cool of you Romania.
I didn't know Romania had TV
Remember the kid who made the 0  suscriber special and then the 1 suscriber special?
He recently reached 100k and got a silver play button
Can the 9yrs old army get him to a million suscribers
Dane -what an absolute mad lad
Dane, What this is actual channel though I can never find it it finally came he's already at
200,000 subscribers he did this here is subscriber special two years ago
Ok this guy this guy's been on a grind for a long time I can respect that Katie PI helps
we want to become the most disliked video on YouTube YouTube schedule says a to removing active Sims
beauty pipe ah
to be fair I only lost like 40K
OK!
Make that back like that not a problem
next petition for kids to make an episode of Lu why would sorting by new so he can see us the unfunny part
Ok let's do it
Let's go through all the trash free mr. Bies he is in jail this is what you guys actually have to sift through
It's pretty cool. Oh bun gates in my mind guy thank you egg
2025 subscribe to Petey pie no hint I haven't got shut it down
I'll not stand for this what happened to anti habit. I had to pay the loan for my first suit
Shut up crab song petitions her pits to reflect back to you with the ice
Why did I not think of that I have it hey know deku want a sponsor another video
Questions for page when is the annual bottle flip
Championship 2018 well it's still 2018 isn't it
Stop complaining how did this design came about I designed it your dumb asses where is your sign I don't know
Why are you afraid of Muppet cuz if getting Muppets Christmas story it's a goddamn most terrifying movie I've seen in my life
Let's goddamn ghost in the Attic when Felix can't upload I lost two teasers video because people keep subscribing
Suffering
Now I know how he feels like, we ?
had this video
That was ready to go up because it looked like t-series is gonna pass me
Without now that it's looking that it's never gonna happen so
I'm suffering from. Success, that's real hard
1.3 million are you kidding me
TV series
Bye
It's a trap the nine year old Army has been tricked again
before shaving I have to shave
who would have thought
Brad was a
Slob
Funny thing is Brad where's that type of black cap all the time as well if anyone can find him wearing that cap you'll
you'll see the resemblance
I'm making a mod called PTA
Okay, wait boots left on a hook
That looks dope the music fits perfectly
It really similar to the beat I've never hit me actually
That's pretty dope please let him see this took me a long time I miss the old studio
decoration and sleepy yeah
Well do you not think I miss my dead pet - thank you very much for that by the way I am adding stuff I
Literally haven't had no time to work on the studio found a to kill a void
while looking through petabytes common replies on the ears video PewDiePie
Damn ear must be famous you better watch out though if the media sees your coming here they'll say you're not see god, damn it
How did it why do you know what Warren missed?
This could have been avoided shoutout to Brad for literally sitting through footage of pills looking
Hey
Number 19 on gaming though. Huh who said I wasn't a gamer who dare tell it if anyone says?
I'm really not a gamer anymore show him this that'll show him do you smoke every time T series overtakes me your long
competition for views to higher Slovak wieners Brad for
Hire me as editor I mean they practically look identical. I don't think anyone would notice a difference all
Anyone ever wonder what is Brad's
reaction with editing I
vote for Brad to
Upload a video of him editing pewds video see we thought about this that kiss Brad streams online and then maybe he could just stream
Himself, editing the problem is
The problem is for some people that
I'm a you save some things
That don't actually make it to the final cut and if those things end up in a live stream then
It's goodbye PewDiePie okay Brad has been my filter for the last six years
you India you win but you swap you little Ariana's reactions can take a joke
I'm actually scared Brad flashes text up on the screen too fast for me to read me it's rude
We have a single mission, we don't like you teach series smash there. Subscribe
That's really dope that's some high quality
poster maybe that could go in the background look at that like that's like actually printable
Allen Portillo calm very cool
Is that bread 1 and bread too. Ok? Let's do
That's really cool just drove past
These kids doing their part in the pouring rain I went to the grocery store at an hour later they're still out there with
Getting some feelings I
Love the fact that someone else posted this and not themselves
They're really just out there I'm 9ag apologist and this is my third time trying to upload this
Many hours oh Jesus Christ
That is crazy
This is strangely hypnotizing and
arousing, oh my god
I can't stop looking at it so weird the Queen the stream Queen
animation Queen slop cricket coffee Shrek adidas adidas
What the Frick u-turn removes 58 million videos featuring hateful and inappropriate content
No single video pits covered
There was thought of that that's hilarious
I mean customers and welcome to bunnies Wollongong as the time is now two minutes past 7:00 this store has
officially ceased trading for this evening
Could you please assist our team by finalizing the purchases and making your way to the registers at the front of the store
I'd like to take this opportunity to thank you for shopping at running Guangdong and a friendly reminder to subscribe to PewDiePie
yes
Spike from t-series just like you 231 plant more trees
Save the bees clean the Seas and I'll see you all tomorrow morning at 7 a.m
Wait well is the shop Bunnings rare house is doing their part
thank you very much oh my god fan art correction god dammit can I not have one nice picture do you really have to
Do you have to do this every single, goddamn time new subs getting angry about Puetz call it being: I see me first time
Really well
Saw this isn't colombo sri lanka
please series
how does this keep happening
Who's doing this it's from this guy that's might not realize the game is the biggest YouTube channel in the world
Thank You Minya very cool okay I performed with sivanna
Oh that genuinely made me have a that's so funny alright guys
we're gonna have to end that episode there thank you so much for all the love and support the Lola why
Why the merchant link in description
Bye!